so let's take a look is this statement
correct no because here we're passing
the user ID and that's not correct you
have to pass the key of the ancestor so
here is this code correct we are passing
the user key so that's right but oh
something's missing here it needs to be
conferenced class not just conference
and here this is right we're loading
type conference dark class and we're
passing the ancestor key correct and
over here in the conference API java
file have a quick look at the definition
forget conferences created again we
annotate it as an appy method specify
the name the path and the HTTP method
post so this time because we need the
user to be logged in we do pass the user
argument and we have to throw an
unauthorized exception in case that user
is not logged in so here's the code very
familiar by now for throwing the
exception if the users not logged in we
get the user ID get user ID we get the
key of the user from their ID because
remember we use the user ID to generate
the key and here we do the query we low
off you load top type conference class
specify the user key is the ancestor to
order by name and then finally we
execute the list to actually run the
query after you deploy your app to
localhost you can test it in the api's
Explorer so here's the conference API
here you see the get conferences created
method that you just defined you are
going to need to make sure that you
refresh your browser or you won't see it
drill down into it I'm going to execute
it oh look forgot to authorize that's
because we required the user argument so
i authorize now we'll try again and here
i see in the response the conference's
that i've created so the UI calls the
same function it calls the gate
conferences created you could also use
the conference's created page in the UI
because when you go to that tab it
actually calls the same method that
you've just created you can use
whichever you prefer the tab in the UI
or the API
Explorer to check that the function
works